Last Friday was That Sucks Day,
the one day a year
when we're allowed to talk
about all the things
that suck in our lives--
from bad haircuts
to manspreading on the subway
to how Chris Hardwick sucks
corporate (bleep)
'cause he liked
the Walking De finale.
Uh, and... we missed our chance,
and that sucks.
So, comedians, let's celebrate
That Sucks Day right here,
right now, by venting
about things that suck.
In 60 seconds. And begin. Tom.
My new inflatable dartboard.
-Yes. Points. Chris.
-Terrible.
Covering up concussion studies
in a multi-billion-dollar
sports league.
All right.
What would you know about that?!
Points. Tom.
Uh, whatever's on the other side
of that weird hole
-in my dressing room.
-All right, points.
-Rachel.
-People on Tinder
looking for a partner in crime.
Yeah. All right, points.
Oh, that's so... I know
exactly what you're... Chris.
Using a racial slur
as your team's name.
All right, points. Tom.
People that say, "Oh, my God,
that's so funny"
-instead of actually laughing.
Yeah. -Yes, points.
Points. Rachel.
People that argue
about the Holocaust
under unboxing videos.
-In the comment section.
-All right, points.
-I'm just specifically...
-Yeah. Points. Chris.
Nickelback.
(buzzer sounds)
Well, the science backs it up
now.